Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家分享一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会直接赢取Lisa提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. If you're watching on YouTube, you might well notice this is part of the poorly wing series where I've broken my arm. Why not subscribe and like this video and maybe think about dropping me a comment in as well to tell me what your favourite episode of the podcast has been so far. As I record this, we are in the middle, coming towards the end of the doctorate in clinical psychology application season for this spring. Given that it's such a competitive industry and that the places are so highly sought after, then it's understandable that emotions can run high from time to time, if not much of the time. And recently I'd seen a post on Twitter that had said,
我是Marianne Trent博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你正在YouTube上观看，你可能会注意到这是“受伤系列”的一部分，因为我的手臂骨折了。为什么不订阅并点赞这个视频呢？也许还可以考虑在评论区留言，告诉我到目前为止你最喜欢播客中的哪一集。录制这期节目时，我们正处于今年春季临床心理学博士申请季的中后期。鉴于这是一个竞争极其激烈的行业，名额非常抢手，因此人们的情绪偶尔（甚至经常）会比较激动是可以理解的。最近我在Twitter上看到一条帖子说，
can those who have offers already for the declineside and still have interviews coming up, at least consider just accepting one. So others on reserve lists for interviews can at least have a chance of getting at least one offer without having to wait another year whilst being poor. So I hear you. It's very, very difficult if you are on a reserve list and if you feel like this affects another year of your development and your opportunities. But also I think it's worth saying that the people who have interviews and even those who have offers have still earned the right to attend those interviews. So today we're going to be looking at whether it's okay to still attend interviews for any psychology profession or area
那些已经拿到临床心理学博士录取通知，但后续还有面试的人，能不能考虑至少接受一个offer？这样，在面试候补名单上的其他人至少有机会获得一个名额，而不必在贫困中再等一年。我听到了你们的心声。如果你在候补名单上，并且觉得这影响了你又一年的发展和机会，那确实非常非常困难。但我也认为值得一提的是，那些获得面试机会甚至拿到offer的人，依然有权参加这些面试。所以今天我们要探讨的是，如果你已经有了工作offer，是否还可以继续参加其他心理学职业或领域的面试。
if you already have a job offer. I'll be guiding you through a few of my thoughts, feelings, insights and reflections on this. But if you've got some of your own, I would love you to come and tell me what you think to this. Come over to the Aspiring Psychologist Community brackets free group on Facebook and let me know what you think. And if you're watching on YouTube, let me know in the comments. So generally speaking, when going to interviews for probably non-psychology roles, or maybe even if it's a psychology private practice role or private institution role, one of the advantages about going to a job interview when you already have a job offer is that you might be able to use that for salary negotiation. Clearly in NHS bandings, that's probably not going to work. But one reason you might want to do that is if you're applying to
我会分享一些我的想法、感受、见解和反思。如果你有自己的看法，我很乐意听听。欢迎加入Facebook上的“有抱负的心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community）免费群组告诉我你的想法。如果你在YouTube上观看，请在评论区留言。总的来说，在参加非心理学职位的面试，或者甚至是心理学私人诊所或私立机构的职位面试时，已经拿到offer再去面试的一个优势是，你或许可以利用它进行薪资谈判。显然，在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）的薪资等级中，这可能行不通。但你可能想这样做的原因之一是，如果你申请的是
a course in the London waiting area where the salary is slightly higher. But of course, that is done for a reason. So that is done because of course, living in and around central London is more expensive. But if you've already committed that you'll be commuting, then you may want to consider doing that. But of course, it is likely your costs for commuting might well be higher as well. So I think it's fair to say that generally speaking, in what is largely an NHS industry for assistant psychologists, but not exclusively, of course, it's unlikely that you'd be wanting to attend that interview to think about using it for salary negotiation, but of course, not impossible. Another reason you might
伦敦及周边地区的课程，那里的薪水略高。当然，这是有原因的，因为在伦敦市中心及周边生活成本更高。但如果你已经决定通勤，你可能需要考虑这一点。当然，你的通勤成本很可能也会更高。所以我认为可以公平地说，在以NHS为主（当然并非全部）的助理心理学家行业中，你不太可能为了薪资谈判而去参加面试，但当然也不是完全不可能。
choose to still attend is to use it as an opportunity for gaining experience. Perhaps all of your interviews in the past have been remote interviews if you've done them over the last few years. So perhaps this is an in-person interview and you'd really like to see what this university or employer is going to be like. And often getting a feel for what the parking is like, what the traffic is like around the area, whether you'd feel safe there, whether you feel like you like aspects of the interview or the course relating to the physical environment and the people that you meet. It might be even meeting people on reception and that they're so lovely that they just make your day and make you feel like you're being put at ease. I know I've spoken in the past about the buffets and the fact that I was given herbal tea at one of the interviews that I attended.
你选择继续参加面试的另一个原因是将其作为获得经验的机会。也许过去几年你参加的所有面试都是远程的，所以这可能是一次面对面的面试，你真的很想看看这所大学或雇主是什么样的。通常，感受一下停车情况、周边交通状况、你是否感到安全，以及你是否喜欢面试或课程在物理环境和所见人员方面的表现，这些都很重要。甚至可能是在接待处遇到的人，他们非常可爱，让你的一天变得美好，让你感到放松。我记得过去曾谈到过自助餐，以及我在参加的一次面试中被提供了花草茶的事。
And those for me were really small factors that made me feel like it was a closely aligned course for me. And when I've attended psychology assistant interviews in the past, one was in Nottingham and one was in Birmingham and the parking was atrocious really really bad and meant I had to leave my car on a side street and then walk and so that was perhaps not going to be ideal in the longer term but sometimes we can only know that when we've walked a mile in shoes to that interview and so also it's worth saying always when you're going somewhere that you're not quite sure what's going to be the deal. Speaking of shoes it might also be an idea when attending interviews in person to take a pair of shoes that are comfortable in your bag so that if it does involve a long walk from a train station or a bus stop or from where you've parked your car if you've driven that you
对我来说，这些都是让我觉得这门课程与我非常契合的小因素。过去我参加助理心理学家面试时，一次在诺丁汉，一次在伯明翰，停车位简直糟糕透顶，我不得不把车停在侧街然后步行，从长远来看这可能并不理想。但有时只有当你真正走过那段路去面试时，你才会知道。所以，当你去一个不太确定的地方时，总是值得注意的。说到鞋子，去参加面对面面试时，在包里带一双舒适的鞋子也是个好主意，这样如果需要从火车站、公交车站或停车的地方走很长一段路，你
can do so in comfort so that you're not limping into your interview when you do get there. Having recently been in central London trying to get somewhere on time for something that I needed to look rather smart for I would also suggest that it might be advantageous if you can afford it to at least get an Uber or a taxi when you're attending the interview because arriving in a big sweaty mess and feeling like you ruined your outfit is also not a good look. So learn from the lady who was in a sort of nicely satiny shirt that did not look good after I'd been hustling. So yeah, having a think about how you might physically attend interviews and feel and look your best and not be completely overwhelmed and stressed out when you get there can be useful too. Anyway, that's a bit of an aside, isn't it? So let's
就可以舒适地走过去，而不至于在到达面试地点时一瘸一拐。最近我在伦敦市中心为了准时参加一个需要看起来很干练的活动，我建议如果负担得起，打个优步或出租车去面试可能更有利，因为满头大汗、感觉毁了装束到达现场并不是一个好的形象。所以，向那位穿着缎面衬衫、在奔波后看起来很狼狈的女士学习吧。所以，考虑一下如何以最佳的身体状态和形象参加面试，而不至于在到达时感到完全不知所措和压力重重，这很有用。总之，这有点跑题了，不是吗？那么让我们
take a quick pause here to take a listen to one of the book jingles and I will catch up with you on the other side. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective The Aspiring Psychologist Collective We're using today's episode to weigh up some factors involved in whether we should or would or could attend interviews in the psychology profession when you've already been offered a job somewhere else. So of course, you have earned this right to have this interview, whether or not you were offered a reserve list place for the interview or an outright place. It's based on your performance in the form, the application that
暂停一下，听听书的宣传片段，稍后回来。有抱负的心理学家集体（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）。我们利用今天的节目来权衡一些因素，探讨在已经获得其他工作offer的情况下，是否应该、是否会或是否能够参加心理学行业的面试。当然，无论你获得的是面试候补名额还是直接面试名额，你都已经赢得了参加面试的权利。这是基于你在申请表中表现出的能力，
you submitted. It might also be linked to any assessment tests or checks that you've done too. And when we're making decisions, sometimes it can be useful to make them as informed a decision as we can how can we know that it's going to be a good fit for us or not a good fit for us for the next one two three four five six could be many years if we haven't been and had a look and checked it out for ourselves and one of the things I loved about in-person interviews, certainly for the doctorate, was the chance to meet other delegates. So if there's going to be a couple of people employed at the same time, for example, when I worked for Boots in Milton Keynes when I was 16, 17, 18, and a little bit older than that as well, we had a group interview and being able to meet people that
也可能与你完成的任何评估测试或检查有关。当我们做决定时，尽可能做出明智的决定有时会很有用。如果我们没有亲自去看看、去核实，我们怎么知道未来一到六年（甚至更久）的时间里，它是否适合我们？我喜欢面对面面试（尤其是博士面试）的一点是，有机会见到其他候选人。例如，当我16、17、18岁在米尔顿凯恩斯的Boots工作时，我们进行了集体面试，能够见到那些
eventually ended up being my colleagues was wonderful, really part of a bonding experience. And when I had my doctorate in clinical psychology interviews, meeting people that would be potentially part of my cohort, in fact, people that I met, I certainly think I met two people on my cohort for the first time at our interview day. So it's a really nice chance to check out the other people, see what you think and whether you feel like you might want to be part of their cohort, because that's clearly the type of candidate that that particular role attracts. Do you get a good feel about the other candidates? And whilst of course when we're looking at selection days that might run over multiple weeks we can't necessarily know that we would be meeting our future colleagues or that we are all going to be the same across all of the interview days. I think it does give you
最终成为我同事的人真是太棒了，这确实是一种建立联系的体验。当我参加临床心理学博士面试时，见到那些可能成为我同学的人，事实上，我确实在面试当天第一次见到了我同期学员中的两个人。所以这是一个很好的机会去观察其他人，看看你的想法，以及你是否觉得你想成为他们群体的一部分，因为这显然是该特定职位所吸引的候选人类型。你对其他候选人感觉良好吗？虽然在跨越数周的选拔日中，我们不一定能见到未来的所有同事，也不一定所有面试日的候选人都一样，但我认为这确实给了你
a very nice feel for how it might be if you were working in that role. So if you are trying to deliberate between, should I? What does it say about me if I do go when I've already had this offer? Then to you, I would say, just says you're a human and that you are allowed to do what you've been offered the opportunity to do. You're also allowed to not go if you choose that you want the chaos to end and you want to take control. But there might be reasons that you're wanting to attend the interviews because actually that course or job is going to be a better fit for you personally geographically maybe even the style of the work or maybe even the supervisor that you might be getting to work with might also be factors that
一种非常好的感觉，让你知道如果在这个职位上工作会是什么样子。所以，如果你在纠结“我该去吗？如果我已经有了offer还去面试，这说明了什么？”那么我想对你说，这只说明你是一个普通人，你有权去做你被邀请去做的事情。如果你选择结束这种混乱并想要掌控局面，你也可以选择不去。但你可能想参加面试的原因是，实际上那个课程或工作在地理位置、工作风格，甚至是你可能共事的导师方面，可能更适合你，这些都是
you're considering maybe you have people that you need to support in your life and that this particular job role or training place is going to suit your needs better. For example, maybe you are a parent and you're aware that actually this course or employer is particularly good at treating parents humanely and so that they can optimally parent their children as much as possible. And in this day and age of social media, you might find that actually networking is a really nice opportunity as well. So if you meet someone at an in-person or even a Zoom interview for that matter, and you really feel like you click, then you might want to add each other on socials and you might well be really useful
你考虑的因素。也许你需要支持生活中的某些人，而这个特定的工作岗位或培训名额更能满足你的需求。例如，也许你是一位家长，你意识到这个课程或雇主特别善于人性化地对待家长，让他们尽可能地照顾好孩子。在社交媒体时代，你可能会发现社交也是一个非常好的机会。所以，如果你在面对面甚至Zoom面试中遇到某人，并且感觉非常投缘，那么你们可以互加社交账号，你们很可能会成为
supports for each other for this next stage of your career or maybe even as a lifelong friendship you never know where it's going to go and that's been a really nice part of the aspiring psychologist membership as well is that the members are so supportive of one another and as people have been getting interview dates and even place offers for the doctorate in clinical psychology people are genuinely thrilled for one another and they're they're not only thanking me but thanking the supportive nature of the group and feeling like they've got everybody rooting for them on their side so if you feel like this industry of ours is making you feel a their side so if you feel like this industry of ours is making you feel a bit lonely or making you feel like others are you know wanting to hack you down
彼此职业生涯下一阶段非常有用的支持者，甚至可能成为终身朋友，你永远不知道未来会怎样。这也是“有抱负的心理学家会员”项目非常棒的一部分，成员们彼此非常支持。当人们获得临床心理学博士的面试日期甚至录取通知时，大家都会为彼此感到由衷的高兴。他们不仅感谢我，还感谢群组的支持氛围，感觉每个人都在为他们加油。所以，如果你觉得我们这个行业让你感到孤独，或者让你觉得别人在想方设法打压你，
so that they can have your place then it might be that you want to consider coming on board to the aspiring psychologist membership and there will be links in the show notes to that but you can also check out details in any of my socials. And if you're on YouTube, there will be a link in the description and on the screen right now too. And as humans, we, you know, we are curious creatures and we like to feel that we are right in our decision. And so it might be that you're feeling like job offer A or course offer A is totally going to be a bit of you. But we can't know what we don't know. We might be pleasantly surprised by what we see, hear, feel and experience at this other interview. And so you can give yourself permission to be curious. And whilst of course, I know it might be really anxiety provoking and sad making for somebody
好让他们取代你的位置，那么你可能需要考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”项目。节目说明中会有相关链接，你也可以在我的任何社交媒体上查看详情。如果你在YouTube上观看，描述栏和屏幕上现在也有链接。作为人类，我们是好奇的生物，我们喜欢感觉自己的决定是正确的。所以，你可能觉得工作offer A或课程offer A完全适合你。但我们无法知道我们所不知道的事情。我们可能会对在另一次面试中看到、听到、感受到和体验到的东西感到惊喜。所以，你可以允许自己保持好奇心。虽然我知道这对于那些
who's not getting an interview this year, I firmly believe that it's a really nice position to be in when you're getting more than one interview offer in a year so that you do get that chance to make a choice and so that it's indicating that not just one course thinks you're ready, that other courses or jobs also think you're ready and you've got something worthwhile to bring. It's not to say at all that if you're not getting interviews that you don't have something worthwhile to bring but I honestly and I've said before that I felt when my time was right my form felt genuine it felt like a bit of me it felt like I was being my genuine self and I was then offered three interviews and it just felt like it was my time and so yeah maybe think if you're not getting
今年没有获得面试机会的人来说，可能会非常令人焦虑和难过，但我坚信，一年内获得多个面试机会是一个非常好的位置，因为你有机会做出选择。这表明不仅有一门课程认为你准备好了，其他课程或工作也认为你准备好了，并且你拥有值得贡献的东西。这并不是说如果你没有获得面试机会，你就没有值得贡献的东西。但我真诚地说过，当我的时机成熟时，我的申请表感觉很真实，感觉就像是我自己，感觉我在展现真实的自我，然后我获得了三次面试机会，感觉时机到了。所以，如果你没有获得
outright interviews or if you're still on the waiting list if you've learned since this podcast was released that you're not being offered interviews this year or for the job that you've applied for think about how you can use these next few months to further and advance your skills, your abilities, your reflections, your insights and to strengthen any weaknesses or bits that you've got gaps in your CV for. You might of course feel that one particular course or job aligns more with your goals or your priorities and the things that you see as exciting and important and worthwhile in psychology profession. It might be that you have a particular interest in doing research under one of the academic staff in a particular course or organisation. Whatever reason you've picked to put that course or that job into your job basket and to apply for
直接面试机会，或者如果你还在等待名单上，如果你在播客发布后得知今年没有获得面试机会，或者没有获得你申请的工作，请思考如何利用接下来的几个月来进一步提升你的技能、能力、反思和见解，并加强你简历中存在的弱点或空白。你当然可能觉得某门课程或工作更符合你的目标或优先事项，以及你在心理学职业中认为令人兴奋、重要和有价值的事情。也许你对在特定课程或机构的某位学术人员指导下进行研究有特别的兴趣。无论你选择将该课程或工作放入你的“工作篮子”并申请的理由是什么，
it is valid and important and you're allowed to have a shot at that and make your mind up and of course if other people do have multiple interviews and then they all get to choose it's of course useful for those on the reserve list for actual places, not just interviews. And honestly, I would love to be a fly on the wall when people get the phone call or the email to offer them reserve list places. I turned down one place to accept another and yeah just knowing that you've potentially changed someone's life and you know and altered their career trajectory and knowing the celebration and the joy that they'll be feeling and experiencing for themselves but also likely with their family and their support networks around them so incredible and yesterday I had a voice note from one of my
它都是有效且重要的，你有权去尝试并做出决定。当然，如果其他人有多个面试机会，他们都可以选择，这对那些在候补名单上的人（不仅仅是面试候补）当然是有用的。老实说，当人们接到电话或邮件通知他们进入候补名单时，我真想成为墙上的苍蝇去看看。我曾拒绝了一个名额而接受了另一个，知道你可能改变了某人的一生，改变了他们的职业轨迹，并知道他们自己（以及他们的家人和支持网络）会感受到的庆祝和喜悦，这真是太不可思议了。昨天我收到了一位
members telling me that they had been offered a place on a course. And honestly, I dissolved into tears as I was leaving a voice note in response because it really does matter. It's such a big deal. And it's so wonderfully affirming when people are getting the news and they're getting that message that yes they they they are chosen they are doing they're moving in the right circles they're saying the right things and they're going to get to advance to the next stage of their career and honestly I could cry again. I just feel like I've got the best job in the world. And thank you for all of you who've been so kind about the podcast and about the books and the membership. If you've got any questions or anything you'd like to say about
成员的语音留言，告诉我他们被某门课程录取了。老实说，我在回复语音留言时泪流满面，因为这真的很重要。这是一件大事。当人们得到消息，收到那条“是的，他们被选中了，他们正在进入正确的圈子，他们说对了话，他们将进入职业生涯的下一个阶段”的信息时，这真是太令人欣慰了。老实说，我又要哭了。我觉得我拥有世界上最好的工作。感谢所有对播客、书籍和会员项目如此友善的人。如果你有任何问题或想说的话，
this episode, do let me know. I'm not any less sad for you if you don't have interviews to go to, or if you are waiting to hear back. I am moved by your distress as well. But I firmly believe that your time is coming, and you will get there when you're ready for this next stage of your journey. Thank you so much for listening and for being part of my world. If you're listening to this episode when it comes out, hope you've had a marvellous coronation weekend with all of the scones that you might choose to eat and hope the sun has shone for you. Wishing you all of the best of luck with any interviews you might have coming up or with being offered places for interview or on a course if you're on a reserve list. I love
请告诉我。如果你没有面试机会，或者正在等待回复，我并不会因此而减少对你的同情。我也被你的痛苦所触动。但我坚信你的时机即将到来，当你准备好迎接旅程的下一个阶段时，你就会到达那里。非常感谢你的收听，感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你在节目发布时收听，希望你度过了一个美妙的加冕周末，吃了你选择吃的烤饼，希望阳光为你照耀。祝愿你在即将到来的任何面试中，或者在候补名单上获得面试或课程名额时，一切顺利。我喜欢
celebrating with you. So do come and hook up with me on social media. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere because I love to celebrate your wins. So keep having them, hold your head high, do your brilliant best self. And I will look forward to catching up with you on the next episode, which is available from 6 a.m. on Monday. Take care. With this podcast, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical
与你一起庆祝。所以一定要在社交媒体上与我联系。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent，因为我喜欢庆祝你的胜利。所以继续保持，昂首挺胸，展现你最出色的自我。我期待在下一期节目中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点发布。保重。通过这个播客，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是Dr. Marianne Trent的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者学员。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现关于如何达到目标的所有不同故事非常有趣，成为心理学家没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我在做错什么，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床
psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。目前还没有关于本集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。